cherries off today so your most accurate
weather now forecast live local and
right now starts with this view
from our camera top of the bank of
america hector's talking about the
freeways today watching the sky
a couple of stray clouds and it is still
warm just not
as hot the excessive heat warning
expired at eight o'clock last night and
welcome to summer which started a half
hour later so officially it's 88 degrees
we're down to 84 at the lakes 85s for
summerland and mountains edge you're at
80 up in centennial hills i hesitate to
use the word cool but it's cooler than
it has been
henderson you're at 91 the wind is going
to be a bigger factor today along with a
continuation of heat and look at death
valley dropping out of
triple digits to laughlin you're at 94.
take away 10 for searchlight as we
continue with our nevada
and beyond you're the low 50s ely mid
60s up in lincoln county good morning to
cedar city with a 70
over the hump in prop you got 86. so
we're going for 109 today so don't get
the idea that
with no excessive heat warning it's not
going to be hot just not
hot enough for that warning record high
of 114.
low this morning so far 88. we'll see if
that turns out to be a record for
a record warm overnight low high
pressure will build
again later this week so the
temperatures are going to climb back
up we're also watching what was tropical
storm claudette then became an extra
tropical depression going across the
deep south
now expected to be and is renamed
tropical storm claudette again
we're talking about upwards of a foot of
rain along the gulf coast fatal car
crashes tornadoes
we'll see what happens with the
carolinas later today
for you how about the 104 after a 109
today by the way winds could be gusting
upwards of 30 miles an hour tonight
you'll wake up in the mid 80s tomorrow
low 80s
for tuesday night into wednesday some
neighborhoods may not even see the
century mark on wednesday but then we'll
all start climbing right back up
could be 110 again on sunday